do you know peter parker who's
spider-man yes is that him no
hello guys and welcome to another
spider-man no way home video in this
video we have been given a very big
tease for toby maguire spider-man now we
have been teased of toby spider-man
several times throughout the official
trailers but i would say this is the
biggest one yet um this one cannot be
misinterpreted uh this one is very
direct and there's no other way to look
at it doc oct is in fact referring to
toby maguire spider-man now what i
really love about this clip is um how
confused tom holden spider-man is i
would say this scene probably takes
place uh towards the start of the film
just because at this point in time we
know he doesn't know about nova
spider-man or hasn't seen the other
spider-man if not he wouldn't look so
confused now i'm just really hoping
we'll get a scene between doc ocht and
toby maguire spider-man it seems like
doc oct was hoping to see toby as well
instead of tom holland spider-man um i
wonder what point in time um doc ock
will be dragged into this new um
universe because we know in spider-man 2
doc ock's um was actually redeemed by
the end of the film and it looks like in
this film his cause and destruction and
mayhem again and he looks like he's a
villain so this makes me wonder towards
the end of the film will doc ock become
good again will he actually team up with
the spider-man to fight darva villains
there's also a scene in the trailer
where it looks like um dr octopus
actually gets attacked by electro so
this just makes me think this will
actually happen so let me know what you
guys think of this in the comment
section below also the run time for
spider-man no way home has come out and
it's about two hours and 28 minutes um
this is including the credits so do keep
that in mind however i think this is
like the fourth longest marvel film to
date anyway guys what do you think of
this topic mcguire tease this is the
biggest tease we have to date so it's
quite exciting to see i wonder if we get
more teasers of tobin guy and andrew
garfield spider-man up to the film's
release also if you did enjoy this video
please like and subscribe to show your
support and turn notifications on so you
don't miss future videos thanks for
watching guys